[Música]
y con nuestro primer invitado del día me
hablamos de los planes energéticos del
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador luego de que la cámara de los
diputados mexicanas rechazara la reforma
constitucional al sector energético
impulsada por obrador la medida no
alcanzó los dos tercios de los votos
necesarios por lo que el mandatario dio
a conocer entonces su plan b que
consiste en una reforma a la ley minera
con miras a proteger la explotación del
litio en ese país es que ayer lunes el
senador recibió para su análisis
discusión y votación el texto de una
reforma a esta ley minera que
nacionalice el litio horas después de
que su aprobación en la cámara de
diputados fuera hecha realidad esta
iniciativa
declara de utilidad pública la
exploración y explotación y
aprovechamiento del litio además busca
que no haya concesiones ni contratos
para la explotación de este material y
establece que ésta es sólo
responsabilidad del estado mexicano que
también creará un organismo
descentralizado para este fin y para
ello para analizar todo lo que se quiera
hacer con el litio y qué pasó ayer con
esta reforma que no pasó la aprobación
del senado quiero saludar entonces a rne
césped él es analista y asesor de la
industria energética y economía cuenta
con 28 años de experiencia en industria
de hidrocarburos gracias franceses por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francés de 4d pregunto entonces por qué
esta iniciativa de obrador que busca el
mandatario con esta reforma a la energía
del país
bueno bueno y error bueno yo creo que lo
que buscaba el día domingo que bueno que
no fue aprobado un entrenado caso es que
la comisión para la electricidad fuera
la garante de la generación de la
electricidad pero creo que habíamos
caído un error y ya vemos porque todos
los que estamos involucrados en este
sector tenemos de entender que la
comisión creada electricidad hoy en día
tiene el control del 81 por ciento del
total de la generación de la
electricidad porque porque los permisos
que se llaman productores independientes
que son pies que son unos permisos que
se le dieron en su momento dado cuando
salió el tratado de libre comercio en
1998 para generar el interés necesaria
para la industrialización y sobre todo
para los acuerdos comerciales que en su
momento bueno estas empresas sólo podían
venderle la luz a la comisión federal de
electricidad y los segundos sólo a
subasta de largo plazo que surgieron
después de la reforma energética en
donde están las energías eólica y solar
es por eso que la comisión de crea tiene
hoy el 81 por ciento dicho esto creo que
no se ha entendido en méjico que la
transición energética no es sólo la
generación y el domingo nos dimos cuenta
que no existe todavía un plan de largo
plazo en el país existen ciertas
avenencia ciertas propuestas pero en
méxico no hay un plan de largo plazo y
esto va a causar una gran dificultad
porque no estamos viendo hacia
hacia el futuro qué es lo que debe de
venir ramsés qué dificultades se puede
generar en méxico todo lo que está
ocurriendo actualmente
bueno principalmente hoy en la mañana si
hubieran visto los últimos 10 días el
precio del gas natural el año pasado
estaba en tres dólares más o menos el
millar de btu a finales de diciembre de
2021 subió a seis dólares y hoy lo
encontramos a casi el 750 y el día de
ayer rosso casi los 8 dólares esto qué
significa el méxico el 60 por ciento de
la generación de la electricidad depende
del gas natural hoy estamos viendo sobre
todo la que la unión europea va a dejar
de comprar el hidrocarburos a rusia y
sobre todo lo del gas natural y lo que
va a afectar a méxico es que nosotros
dependemos en gran parte del gas que no
está vendiendo eeuu hoy eeuu está
volteando hacia el mercado europeo sobre
todo a la venta del gas natural licuado
y hoy en europa este el gas natural
estaba valiendo de acuerdo a los datos
en el mercado holandés que de referencia
a entre 30 y 33 dólares enviar de veto
imagínate nosotros si dependemos de eeuu
sólo estamos discutiendo el quién va a
generar pero no el cómo vamos a generar
la electricidad en el corto y en el
mediano plazo claro anses y con todo
esto que estamos viviendo en méxico
también mundialmente con todo lo que
está pasando en la guerra y también el
calentamiento global que pasa una
transición más rápida a esas energías
renovables a esas energías limpias y
limpias tanto en méxico como en el resto
del mundo porque no volcarnos hacia esta
energía y seguir peleando por estos
hidrocarburos tan contaminantes porque
ayer también se dijo que este plan de
lópez obrador aumentaría las emisiones
contaminantes
y creo que aquí hay que entender algo
muy importante en menos de 60 días la
adicción energética a nivel mundial se
aceleró porque digo porque el gas
natural iba a ser parte de la transición
y en el mundo hay dos fases de
transición que hay que explicar la
primera es cómo vas a generar la
electricidad y la eléctrica lo que
quiere hacer es que se emita la menor
cantidad de emisiones de dióxido de
carbono o de gases de efecto invernadero
y la segunda fase es que todos los
motores de combustión que hoy utilizan
combustibles de hidrocarburos fósiles se
dejen de usar por carros de tipo
eléctrico para entender cero emisiones
en los motores pero esto va a tardar
como en el año 2100 que es lo que vamos
a tener una transición completa en
méxico no hemos entendido esto que el
gas natural que se tenía contemplado
utilizarse entre dos a tres décadas
pases la transición a renovables en su
totalidad bueno el gas natural se va a
cortar esta utilización yo creo que no
más de dos décadas y esto lo que va a
acelerar la tensión energética en méxico
lo que hemos no hemos entendido es que
le das toda la comisión dura de
electricidad un presupuesto no más de
500 mil millones de pesos que es sólo
para operar ahora tendrás que darle en
el 2024 cuando menos un 30 un 40 por
ciento más para ti plantas eficientes y
sobre todo las que tiene actualmente
volverlas todavía más que reduzcan las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
ramsés para nuestra audiencia
internacional para entender un poco qué
pasa con la energía en méxico le quiero
preguntar si este tema está siendo
politizado en su país porque recordamos
que también el día de ayer el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador dijo que los
que se opusieron a esta medida a la
medida del día de ayer que no que no
pasó pues por el senado la tumbaron
también la posición con pues todos los
dos senadores alzando la voz para no
pasar esta medida los tildó como
traidores a la patria realmente entonces
la energía está politizada en mexico que
pasa son traidores de la patria los que
supusieron esta medida más bien dicho yo
creo que en la discusión en el poder
legislativo tenemos que subirla un
poquito más de nivel en el sentido de
llegar a un plan de largo plazo lo que
vimos el día domingo son
posicionamientos de partidos que
representan a todos nosotros y lo que
diga el poder ejecutivo bueno está
dentro de sus derechos porque todos
podemos expresar lo que pensamos en su
momento pero hay que dejar bien claro en
méjico nosotros nos convertimos en un
país ex en 'la en donde cada
administración que ha llegado la actual
y la del futuro yo creo que va a ser así
es que cada quien realiza sus planes y
sus políticas públicas en función de lo
que consideran en el periodo que está
aquí hay algo muy importante que hay que
entender nosotros tenemos un acuerdo
comercial que es el tema y ya lo ha
dicho el embajador que está quien está
de eeuu aquí en méxico y varios
representantes de eeuu que que van a
respetar la soberanía y las cuestiones
políticas que se decían y en el tema que
está bien establecido lo que sí hay que
respetar son los tratados y acuerdos
porque el acuerdo del tema no es de
cuestión ideológica política los
acuerdos comerciales en donde se firma
en el 2020 por esta administración y se
basó principalmente en la reforma
energética y hay que dejar claro la
reforma energética
es el plan es una herramienta que se
debería utilizar para hacer un plan el
cual no se ha hecho en mexico y emboqué
decir lo que nosotros apenas tenemos 5
años de un nuevo mercado porque hemos de
recordar que antes del 2013 toda
iniciativa privada que quería estar el
sector energético tenía que licitar a
por medio de comisión para electricidad
o vía pemex hoy hay la oportunidad de
hacerlo en forma independiente cada uno
se proyecta con todo esto entonces
ramsés se dejaría de hacer inversiones
extranjeras en méxico con un terreno
político no tan claro para estas
empresas extranjeras de acuerdo también
a este tratado que usted lo estaba
mencionando el tema
y creo que es importante lo que va a
comentar uno porque el año pasado eeuu
en inversión extranjera directa en un
inyector méxico alrededor de 15 mil
millones de dólares el sector energético
en el 2013 no pasaba del 3% del total de
la inversión extranjera directa
anualizada y hoy está representando casi
entre el 20 el 20 por ciento con la
reforma energética actualmente de 1999
más menos 2021 la inversión extranjera
directa el 40 por ciento de toda esta en
el sector energético ha ido en la
generación de la electricidad creo que
la licitud no le da certidumbre y
estamos viendo que cada 10 complicado
tener recursos estamos viendo que los
bancos centrales están aumentando el
costo del dinero
vemos una inflación que no está
controlada vemos que el precio de los
combustibles no pueden bajar porque los
precios del barril están subiendo y se
han mantenido por los 100 dólares y lo
que vemos es que todavía la derivación
que estamos viendo de rusia ucrania no
sabemos cuándo va a pagar y dejar bien
establecido que hoy tenemos no una
guerra bélica como los que tuvimos en
los siglos pasados pero sí una primera
guerra desde el punto de vista
financiero energético y en él debemos de
ver después de que resulte todo esto
cómo va a estar la nueva geopolítica
energética en el mundo ahora hablemos
del litio el llamado plan b presentado
por el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador que tan importante es el
litio y qué tanta razón tiene amplió de
querer nacionalizar su explotación es
beneficioso para el mercado energético
mexicano
no no no a ver yo creo que hay que
explicar algo importante hay una
confusión el litio no es como el oro
plata o el hierro que es un mineral que
tú puedes estar en forma pura no el
litio lo importante es sacar los
derivados del mismo porque está
impregnado en la formación y el litio lo
importante es el carbonato del hidrógeno
del litio por ejemplo hoy en los
mercados en china el carbonato de litio
que es el equivalente está alrededor la
tonelada de 70 mil dólares la tonelada
el año pasado hace un año y medio a dos
años estaba más o menos en diez mil
dólares ya subió a casi seis veces su
valor el litio se encuentra en el mundo
en tres formas y esto lo quiero decir
para que quede bien claro se encuentra
en salmueras que es lo que puede
encontrar en sudamérica que perfora un
pozo 200 metros sacas de la salmuera lo
pones en piscinas y entre 12 y 14 meses
puede sacar una tonelada de litio para
hacer el carbonato el hidróxido de litio
tiene la otra la roca dura que es como
los minerales que tú extra estructuras
lo lavas y haces un procesos
físico-químicos que tiene un periodo de
12 a 14 meses cuál es el problema en
méxico en méxico tenemos la élite
impregnado en una roca sedimentaria de
arcilla que cuando ustedes van al campo
no sé si han visto el lodo cuando le
echas agua se pone chicloso a es así
como está hoy en día el litio en nuestro
país en la mina que está en sonora hoy
este tipo de formación solo en el mundo
está en fase de investigación y no hay
más de 5 minas de este tipo en méxico lo
que existe es que sólo hay una
certificación del litio que se le da que
es tan sonora y todavía está en fase de
exploración y lo que hemos encontrado en
las de masa de formación es que el
sistema geológico mexicano ha
determinado es que sólo existe la
probabilidad y hay que hacer inversiones
para esto para lo cual para tener una
tonelada de litio puede durar entre 6 a
8 años
entre 3.000 y 6.000 millones de dólares
la pregunta aquí es si se va a crear una
empresa estatal del litio del méndez de
mexico como ya dijo atienda no va a
afectar el presupuesto pero alguien
tiene que dejar de tener su dinero ya
sean estados con la parte de desarrollo
económico porque en el desarrollo social
lo veo muy complicado que quiten
presupuesto para crear esta empresa pues
ya lo sabremos a ramsés cuando esta ley
sea derogada o aprueba esta iniciativa
del litio por parte del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
ramsés gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 un gran abrazo